les plus fourbes et on commence avec
deux stages s'élèverait dans un magazine
à propos des fans de sa vie et il évoque
même karine le marchand
regardez où vous tél
[Musique]
après trois concerts anniversaires d'ntm
et un rôle au théâtre joey starr se
confier au magazine marie claire
et lorsqu'on lui demande de citer trois
amante rêver il répond béatrice dalle
encore béatrice dalle et karine le
marchand
bon on sait qu'il entretient toujours
une relation très fusionnelle avec celle
qui reste le grand amour de sa vie mais
pauvre karine cela ressemble à une maxi
promotion si personne n'en parlait il ya
quelques mois les deux audio semble
aujourd'hui filer le parfait amour
karine nouvelle star john oui j'étais
très étonné parce que et lui et elles
ont toujours été quand même relativement
secret sur leur histoire d'amour
j'ai envie de crier leur joie et il
communique à fond avant je sais le rôle
d'eric moche et je sais que tu as
d'ailleurs
oui oui il a commencé sa pièce de
théâtre début mars
et comme par hasard l'histoire avec
karine elle est a commencé début février
sont ils ont une super
[Musique]
ouais ouais super comme je trouve qu'il
accentue vraiment sa relation il est
comme par hasard communiqué il ya des
gens qui n'aiment pas moi j'aime
beaucoup joey starr ya peut-être des
gens qu'il aime pas mais par contre
faire croire que mais oui je mentalise
son histoire d'amour pour faire la
promotion de sa thérapie pour moi c'est
ce que tu veux pas dire son nom mais
parce que vous êtes très amis à karine
avec kaïn comme moi mais ça n'empêche
pas seul on peut pas tout voir son
prisme de l'unité sous prétexte que tu
t'occupes de ce secteur là sur la tête
de ma mère on dirait ta tante qui te
parle un dîner cook matière doit pas
parler comme à des tontons pied
[Applaudissements]
on sait pas vous pu les personnels alors
je ne sais pas si c lire la pièce de
terre mais je trouve comme magali qui
l'utilisent beaucoup l'image de karine
le marchand tu vas mourir
ce qui est fort dans leur exposition
médiatique c'est qu'à aucun moment il
n'affirme ni affirme la nature de leur
relation et même sur une photo on voyait
qu'elle est le marchand dans le lit on
imagine assez nuls soit un mec qui sort
mieux avec des meufs on voit juste le
visage du crime marchands et des médias
s'étaient fantasme mais bon l'amour
aveugle et je pense que parfois le
protéger c'est pas mal d'abord parce que
tu as voulu dire aujourd'hui quand
quelqu'un a le courage de dire qu'il est
amoureux quête d'un second titre ça
suspect d'année ou web asus
regardez là c'est vrai c'est vrai c'est
vrai regardez lui lui il le dit il est
amoureux d'aurore voilà ça va très bien
at amoureuse de patoche jean-michel mère
est amoureuse de l'amour de la france
[Applaudissements]